success requires learning as fast as the
world is changing and we are closer to
the Future than we think I prepared
myself for the future by upskilling with
simply learn simply learn help me
transition from being an oil and gas
professional to a digital transformation
and design thinking professional and
brought me closer to my future goals of
becoming an energy transition leader
with the aim of transitioning my career
I enrolled in the professional
certificate program in digital
transformation by simply learn in
association with Purdue University
hey I am shashikant Pati from Pune India
I am currently working in oil and gas
industry in a Senior Management role
however it has always through the
engineering lens but now I can
amalgamate the Knowledge and Skills from
engineering digital transformation and
design thinking to deliver more
promising Energy Solutions at my current
job
this course helped me broaden my
perspective the comprehensive curriculum
made me learn the basics and then
successfully apply those to my area of
work the interaction with the
instructors and case studies were very
helpful and really helped me learn the
basics of the evolving Digital World my
upskilling journey has been
significantly rewarding I feel extremely
confident about the impact it will have
on my career in the near future this
course has helped me
to contribute to the industry
effectively I can now collaborate my
knowledge of these fields together and
devise more meaningful strategies and
solutions to energy problems
also I try to relax and take a break
from my work life whenever I get time I
am particularly interested in playing
Tabla and zambo
life is about challenging yourself
to everyone out there begin your
upskilling journey now keep learning and
keep up Skilling focus on the value you
can provide and you are already a step
closer to success
[Music]